[Applause]
Demon Slayer is an anime series that
captivates viewers with its stunning
animation thrilling plot and lovable
characters but one of the most appealing
aspects of the show is the incredible
Display of Power by both the heroes and
the villains from the stunning water
breathing to the terrifying upper Moon
demons the explosive battle between
rengoku and akaza or the triumphant
Gathering of the hashiras these are the
top 10 Showcases of power in Demon
Slayer ranked based on their impact on
the plot their creativity and
originality and just their sheer
awesomeness
laughs
first up we have the introduction of the
insect hashiraj shinobu
ild
is one of the most intriguing and
complex characters in Demon Slayer what
she lacks for strength in cutting down
demons she makes up with her cunning and
preference for poisons using a special
sword to inject deadly concoctions one
that aims to make a demon suffer before
the sweet release of death her power
comes from how she uses her hatred for
demons in a more clever way than others
her introduction completely flips our
expectations of what other hashiras
might be and while her introduction is
ranked the lowest on this list the fact
that it even made it here amongst the
numerous flashy sword fights and demonic
blood Arts proves that power can come
from anything Genova's power comes from
harnessing her weakness into her
strength making the demons that are
unlucky to cross her path wishing their
heads were already off their bodies by
the time her poison courses through
their veins
quite possibly one of the few
hand-to-hand beatdowns on this list we
have the battle between nezuko and daki
in the Entertainment District Arc
the fight begins when nezuko arrives at
the scene where tanjiro is battling
an upper ranked demon who can
manipulate her sashes to attack and
devour people daki mocks nezuko for
being a weak and pathetic demon who
can't even help her brother this enrages
nezuko as she undergoes a transformation
that enhances her physical abilities and
gives her access to blood demon art she
unleashes a powerful blast of fire that
burns sashes and injures her she
then engages in close range combat
using her claws fangs and kicks to
overpower her even dagi was taken by
complete Surprise by this version of
nezuko's resilience the fight between
awaken nesuko and daki is a stunning
Display of Power skill and emotion it
shows how far nezuko has come since she
became a demon and how much she cares
for Don Jiro it also shows how and
guildaro are driven by their Twisted
love for each other and their hatred for
humans the fight is a clash of ideals
values and destinies between two pairs
of siblings who have different views
what it means to be a demon
hey
this next one is probably the most
shocking reveal in the Entertainment
District Arc
[Applause]
the introduction of gyotato as the real
main antagonist of the Entertainment
District Arc completely flipped the
minds of us audience and the
protagonists as he proved to be one of
the most formidable enemies that danjiro
and his friends have faced so far he is
introduced as the upper rank 6 demon who
shares a body with his younger sister
the scene of him slowly emerging
from her back when she's about to be
killed by tengen uzui the sound hashira
is a perfect example of how to introduce
a threatening villain with every Demon
Slayer in the room feeling the chill in
the air as this unknown demon appears
after them his Aura even tenses up the
formidable tengin just like how gargoya
appeared after madara's defeat in Naruto
yodaro's introduction is a shocking and
horrifying twist that changes the
Dynamics of the arc it shows that
wasn't the only threat but rather the
hiding spot for an Unstoppable monster
that is her brother
yeah
they're progenitor himself and the
source of all the misery that's been
inflicted on our characters so far
kibutsuji muzan makes it to the list
[Music]
right after Arkansas's Retreat following
his battle with rengoku he then reported
everything back to muzon himself
disguising himself as a child which in
turn just makes the whole scene eerie
and off-putting because of the
contradiction of a child's perceived
personality compared to muzan's
brutality and uncaring personality but
what makes this whole scene more
terrifying and Worthy is the fact that
he made akaza bleed and also probably
fear for his own life due to the mistake
that he made and that he failed to
eliminate the three other demon Slayers
in the scene moves on by simply looking
at him presumably deteriorated and
destroyed his cells which is possible
due to the fact that arcasa originally
received blood from him therefore making
him subservient under his control at all
times the very thought of being under a
cold-hearted and ruthless man's control
at all times is terrifying enough on its
own but if you had in the fact that he's
really hard to please and takes no
excuses for an answer and what you get
is one of the most intimidating villains
in anime currently
the penultimate moment in the
Entertainment District ARG we can add
the final fight between tengen and
Giordano to the list of legendary fights
in this anime
both Fighters are pumped up in their own
way with tengine determined to avenge
his three wives and gyotaro equally
determined to protect his sister the two
Clash with their swords and techniques
creating a spectacle of Sound and Fury
the fight between tengen and giordaro is
a stunning Display of Power skill and
emotion it showcases the strength and
determination of both combatants as well
as their contrasting views on love and
loyalty the final clash between two of
the strongest powerhouses of the season
it's clear however that the real winner
in this fight is the sound hashira
himself with standing and matching
yodaro's attacks blow for blow and
ultimately decapitating him for the
while fighting with only one hand his
determination to will every fiber in his
body to continue to fight and win is
exactly the reason why he's on this list
foreign
in the final moments in the
Entertainment District Arc we get to see
how much zenitsu has improved and grown
over the course of the series and his
new technique godspeed is the
culmination of all of that as the fight
Drew closer to the end zinitsu found
himself trapped under Rubble after being
overwhelmed and beaten by however
using his godspeed zenitsu broke out of
it and then proceeded to use godspeed
again to Blitz with such immense
speed that she didn't even get the
chance to react to it with this speed
zinitsu managed to make an opening which
was later assisted by inosuke to finish
up the fight this fight alone was
teeming with moments that greatly fit
this list and tsunitsu is certainly one
of them despite him only being capable
of using a single form zenitsu still
found a way to work around it by making
other albeit tweaked versions of the
thunder-breathing Fist form zenitsu was
able to produce different variations of
it such as the fist form six-fold and
Eightfold and the newest edition first
form godspeed you can make fun of this
cabinet all you want but that doesn't
take away from the fact that he's a
capable fighter
foreign
block we have danjiro utilizing the
hinokami kagura otherwise known as Sun
breathing
for this battle against rui we really
get to see firsthand what this breathing
style is capable of at the height of the
battle tanjiro is a death store by the
looks of it with his life flashing right
before his eyes he was reminded of his
father's teachings which ultimately
saved his life because this event was
the first instance where hinokamikakura
was used which drastically changed the
flow of the battle with the use of this
breathing technique tanjiro was able to
easily cut rui's threads and gently
overwhelm him with attacks aimed at his
neck yes the sun breathing could do with
a little work for this instance but do
keep in mind this was the first time
danjiro used it and other than that he
was also fighting a demon that's way
more powerful for him to face this early
on in the series he didn't manage to
kill the demon but the fact that he went
toe-to-toe with it and overwhelmed it to
the point that it had to resort to
drastic measures to live just shows how
much power and potential danjiro has
[Music]
thank you
as danjiro is on the verge of death and
running out of options things look dire
for our protagonist when all hope was
lost GUI arrived in the nick of time to
save him and his sister easily nunifying
rui's webs by using a water breathing
technique form that he himself made from
scratch and this act was a feat on its
own the amount of skill and experience
alone needed to accomplish this is
unfathomable but what elevated this
moment more was in the manner that he
dispatches the demon after witnessing
how easily his attack was shredded apart
rui was understandably surprised and
panicked from his perspective his attack
was seemingly rendered useless by an
attack that he himself did not even see
the disrespect didn't end there as
Rooney readies his second attack all we
can see from his point of view is Geo
slowly walking towards him with a flash
of an eye the battle ends with him being
decapitated yet again by an attack they
didn't even see coming this scene alone
shows why hashidas are so revered and
looked upon within the Demon Slayer Corp
not only did guiyu showcase his talent
through the display of a breathing
technique that he invented but he also
showcased his skill by gracefully and
quickly dispatching a demon belonging to
the lower rank of the twelve kizuki and
act befitting the waterhashira indeed
foreign
the fight that broke the internet and
our hearts rangoku vs akaza
[Music]
when talking about a list that's all
about showcasing power then this fight
has not only one but two characters
simultaneously one-upping each other all
throughout the fight the flame hashidara
and Goku going up against the battle
crazed upper Rank 3 akaza in their final
confrontation the two Juke it out as we
get to witness rengoku going all out and
single-handedly taking on one of the six
upper ranking demons all by himself
akaza is dictating the flow of the fight
and slowly overpowering ring Goku all
the while imposing his philosophy onto
him with each flurry of attacks the pair
also received injuries from each other
the only difference is akazar can
quickly recover using his Superior
regeneration it all came to an end
though when rengoku lunges forth with a
powerful and precise blow to akaza but
that strike came at the price of his
life and as the dust settles and Smoke
Clears our Gaza delivers a decisive blow
into rengoku this fight mainly showcased
how threatening and dangerous the upper
six demons are and this fight certainly
conveyed that message pretty well
harengoku great sense of Duty and
steadfastness was a sight to behold
following the death of rui moves on some
of the rest of the lower moons to show
his frustration and disappointment at
them for being an Obsolete and
replaceable part of his 12 gizuki and
what better way to show it than to
personally kill them himself
systematically killing them off one by
one with not even a single chance of
Escape or bargaining one of them did try
to run away but he quickly found out
what happens when you do something like
that when you're in front of your boss
yeah that's right a swift decapitation
we've only seen muzan a couple of times
all throughout the first season of the
show but despite this he completely
dominates every scene that he's in and
the meeting with the lower moons is by
far his greatest Display of Power not
just physical power but also his
influence his mere presence alone is
enough to make demon sweat profusely and
the fact that he can also read the
Demon's very thoughts just makes muzad
all the more imposing the idea that even
in your thoughts that you're not safe is
scary enough on its own if you think
about it a very fitting villain for
being the progenitor of the Demons if I
do say so myself
foreign
picks for the top 10 Showcases of power
in Demon Slayer so far they're about to
be even more awesome displays of power
in the future let me know what you think
in the comment section below see you in
the next one